john what's up so i'm married and my
question is how do we navigate
marriage and raising two kids with
now two very different beliefs a little
backstory is
we've been married for seven years
dating for three prior to that
we have two kids ages three and five my
wife growing up was a jehovah's witness
she stepped away from the faith about
late teens
she
she wasn't in it when we were dating so
she had talked about it a little bit
um but wasn't a part of it but now all
of a sudden she wants to go back
and she actually is going back okay um
what makes it hard is their their
beliefs are
are strongly different uh no birthdays
no holidays
um i feel like a single parent
yeah number
one i hate that for you john because
your whole world just got turned upside
down and i'm
i am just going to sit here for a second
and grieve with you if it sucks man
and i hate that for you um
does a junior wife have leading up to
this does she just come in one day and
lay this on you
has she been thinking about this has
there been um
challenges in your marriage or is this
just out of the blue
she she's mentioned it before um
and i think a big push is her mom okay
who's not around she's east coast so
we're west coast um
her mom is a big influence on her and so
i think uh
covid is also another issue she she
brought that up saying that
she started talking about prophecies and
how things are starting to come true
and uh and the faith she wants
what they believe in to happen for her
and the kids
she would like me to join in on it and
i'm just not
i don't agree with that right
so what do you want to do
and that's that's where i'm i'm stuck
we're we love each other we're married
we're
we're in it for the long haul but now
now it's
our way of life is turned upside down
and
i just don't know what to do going
forward okay
for those again for those listening to
this who
aren't in these universes i want to to
spell a broader picture
um often folks who aren't
in any particular faith community or
are in faith communities that may be
more universal in nature
there are certain faith communities that
have a
deep heartfelt ideation that
if it doesn't isn't happen this way
somebody's soul is going to be tortured
forever and
these conversations can be existential
in nature when
my version of endings and your version
of endings don't match
it's not simply a matter of well you can
go to that building on sunday and i'll
go to this building and then we'll just
meet up for lunch
it can be much deeper than that right
john right okay
one of their beliefs was uh blood
transfusions she does not believe in
that
okay and so god forbid something happens
and she's
with the kids and one of them gets hurt
she's not gonna agree to
saving her child's life right so
here's here's the
man i'm wading into deep waters here but
here's the reality
you're fortunate in this conversation
because you and your wife both love each
other
okay and you have to start from that
place
and you need to have a conversation that
is less about religion
less about beliefs and more about
how are we going to honor and take care
of these kids well
she makes this big transition while you
come to terms with what your new
relationship is going to look like
and what the day to day is going to look
like what the week to week what the
month to month year to year is going to
look like
and then you need to get into the
nitty-gritty and some of these
transitions in your mind are going to be
bigger than they are in reality meaning
you're going to have
conjured up in your head this and this
and this
um she's not if your kid's in a car
wreck and they're racing her to the
hospital she's gonna sign a paper and
say no blood transfusion i'm gonna let
my kid die on the table
so you need to know the doctors won't
let that happen okay
um but there may be other alternatives
where you say
my kids will get the medical care that
they need i will not budge on that
period right um i am going to throw my
child
a birthday party period
okay and so what you need to get in your
head is
the non-negotiables right and
have a conversation with your wife ask
her what are the non-negotiables
because now she gets both sides right
she's been there she left she was
um with you and you're are you just in a
protestant faith uh
yeah okay so you're she's been in that
world
and then she transitioned out my guess
is she's gonna transition again
in a number of years right she will move
around in these conversations and so
what i want you to do is to have your
non-negotiables have heard on
negotiables and y'all sit down and talk
through them
okay if you find a situation where your
kids aren't
safe you've got a bigger problem okay
or you believe your kids aren't safe you
have a larger issue here
um if my guess is it's not going to be
the case
correct it might be but probably not
okay
um my guess is there's going to be a lot
more similarity than you think and
the rug got pulled out from under you in
a pretty significant way
and my guess is she's hurting too she's
trying to figure this out as well
so number one you're gonna get there in
love you're gonna figure out what is
best for our kids
and then you're gonna continue to double
down on connection and see if there's
any sort and i may be nuts here but any
sort
of compromise moving forward
right and it may be knowles holds no
holds barred
i am taking my kids to this place we are
doing this thing
at which point you and her need to go
see a marriage counselor immediately
because then your marriage is going to
be on life support
okay okay i know you're committed to it
but if you have strong protestant
beliefs and you have
kids if you have strong values and
beliefs of any sort
and somebody else particularly your wife
is imposing different values and beliefs
on your kids
that that contradict those there's no
way your marriage survives that
okay that if you don't have a spirit of
love and connection and compromise there
okay
and here's here's the magic i want you
to be open with your kids
as you have these conversations okay
how old are they three and five three
and five okay so that's it hard now
because
she is she's obviously teaching what she
believes now and so
and they're not doing this out of spider
hate or anything but
they they'll make comments oh dada
doesn't know jehovah
sure stuff like that or why doesn't that
uh pray to jehovah
it's they're they're innocent kids but
that's her teaching
them this stuff and it's it's hard it's
hard to sit at the dinner table and do
that
it is and if it aligns with your values
and beliefs you need to let her know
that i'm also going to tell this story
one about jesus one about who i believe
in one about who
i believe this how this narrative plays
and it's gonna feel like you're you're
going to throw these kids into a tizzy
and they're not going to know up from
down and side to side
um you're not they're going to hear the
integrity in your voice you're going to
hear the integrity in your wife
and they're going to hear two adults
approaching a problem having different
outcomes but they're all going to be
rooted in connection there does that
make sense
it does it does and kids are incredibly
resilient
they understand like here's a here's
this is a this is an off the wall
example if it's a terrible one
don't send me mean cards and letters
whatever um
i'm late to everything i try so
hard john i can't tell you how hard i
try
my wife is 15 minutes early to
everything
okay and it drives me crazy that we
leave that much time on the table we
just get somewhere and we
sit and people are still filing in and
it drives her crazy that we are always
running in and we're always late right
right
my kids know that i'm trying
i really am i'm putting some things in
place i'm constantly
working towards discipline and it's a
discipline issue dude i wish it was
something
you know psychosomatic it's it's
discipline for me
and she is constantly working on having
a little more fun in life
right loosening up a little bit and my
kids see
two parents who are both people of
integrity both people who have values
both people who have
beliefs and who are approaching going to
the movies differently does that make
sense
yeah so there's not the existential
weight here right there's not the idea
of what's going to happen in the
afterlife and all those other
conversations but there is
if you approach your kids in love you
approach your kids
with connection they're going to be able
to um
they're going to be able to hear and see
you guys okay they love us i'm figuring
this out i'm figuring that out
it's when she says you cannot mention
jesus at my house again
then you are going to have a problem or
when you turn to her and say
you will not talk about praying to
jehovah again in this home
then you are going to have a problem
right
so ultimately you know i'm going to i'm
going to i'm going to back out
you all need to go see a marriage
counselor now right
you only need to go see a marriage
counselor now you want to go talk to
somebody now and begin to work through
some of the
um what this means have somebody else
navigate this with you
your non-negotiables the things that are
you're able to compromise
what birthdays and holidays are going to
look like what church service is going
to look like what
we're going to tell our kids about end
times prophecies verse
this is one of many many many many many
pandemics that have happened in our
in the history of people and so on and
so on and so forth right
um
but double down in love you still love
this lady she still loves you
and that's a great place for you to
start okay
sit down tonight with her and say we're
going to talk about our kids we're going
to talk about the non-negotiables we're
going to go from there
john thank you so much for this call i
do want to know how that conversation
happens
how it goes so call me back let me know
how it goes and let me know how the
non-negotiables call my guess is i'm
almost positive
there's going to be very very few very
few things at the end of the day
that you'll have to go to war on right
now eventually you will eventually
have to butt heads in a hard way and
you'll have to say for me and my house
she'll say for me and my house and
you're gonna have to have some hard hard
conversations
but for right now in the season of
transition the season of pain
double down on love double down on
non-negotiables and make sure those kids
are loved and connected